I was very keen on really fleshing out superman's
early stages of his journey first we had man of
steel and then we went quite a bit darker with
batman v superman and if he were to uh succumb
to the anti-life equation and become bad superman
i really wanted to make sure that we saw the hero
superman and we saw this the true symbol of hope
that the beacon of light before we went down the
path of darkness and then redemption and still
something that i am very keen to flesh out and so
what lessons has he learned he definitely isn't
going to kill anymore and he's definitely going to
make sure that population centers are completely
removed from the equation because now he's
experienced it and now he's thinking about it
and so we get those steps towards building that
that incredible wise version of superman rather
than the you know still wet behind the ears kind
Welcome back everyone this will be my new
superman man of steel 2 video with henry
cavill him just talking about the future of his
superman where he'd like to take the character
and his ideas for man of steel 2 for those of you
wondering he is still trying to get man of steel
2 made at warner brothers even though he's also
talking about playing marvel characters in the
same breath so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos there's going to be a
bunch of big stuff coming up there is a big dc
hbo series that starts in january it's peacemaker
it's gonna be john cena's spin-off from the
suicide squad movie i will be doing videos for
all those episodes we'll also get a lot more
batman trailer videos really soon too and
there is a batman hbo series based on the
proper patents in batman so there's going to
be a lot of big dc stuff happening next year
but recently you probably saw henry cavill
talking about all of his biggest movies his
biggest roles most notably superman in the dc
movies geralt in the witcher netflix series
and during part of that clip that i put at the
beginning of this video he goes into his plan
for the future of superman and where he stands
with the character how he feels about superman
it was set up so wonderfully to to begin that
journey and that is going to inform a lot of
who he becomes you've also probably seen all the
rumors about cameos crossovers and upcoming dc
movies in the next couple of years as well so if
it wasn't clear he's not done as superman at dc
no matter how much he talks about being in the
marvel movies i'm just calling his next superman
movie man of steel 2 for the purpose of this
video they would probably call it superman man of
tomorrow or something more hopeful as for all the
marvel stuff that he's been talking about recently
i did a video for that so i'll link it at the end
of this and down in the description below because
i think a lot of people freaked out when they
heard him start going on at length about playing
marvel movie characters like does that break some
kind of unspoken rule for him to be both superman
in the dc movies and a marvel character at the
same time does that mean that he's done it dc
no that's not what that means he hasn't totally
gone one way or the other yet even though it seems
kind of chaotic over at dc and warner brothers
movies right now but right now there are no less
than four versions of a live-action superman in
the upcoming dc movies and hbo series five if you
include tyler heckland superman on superman at
lois in the arrowverse there are about as many
different versions of superman now than there
are versions of batman in all the upcoming movies
and i'm counting the new supergirl as part of
that because she's just a different iteration of
a superman project like we're gonna do supergirl
instead of doing superman the versions that we
have right now are the multiverse supergirl that
i just mentioned in the flash movie yes the house
of l symbol on her chest looks exactly like henry
cavill superman symbol so they kind of want you
to think that she's from the main justice league
universe or the same version of krypton that henry
cavill superman came from but here's the thing if
you watch the flash trailer video i'll link that
down in the description below because i've already
done a big video for it but ezra miller's flash
finds her hanging up inside michael keaton's
batcave in a prison cell being bombarded with
red sunlight to weaken her so if he's finding her
in another universe like what is she doing here
that means that in michael keaton's batman
universe earth 89 or whatever you want to call it
her pod probably crashed to earth instead of
superman's or there was a superman at some point
either way she's from michael keaton's batman
universe not the main justice league universe
then there's the new superman movie that
warner brothers announced last year with an
african-american actor playing a version of clark
kent superman i consider that to be a multiverse
superman movie right now and there's a separate
michael b. jordan val zod hbo tv series we know
a little bit more about what's going on with that
but that's meant to be a totally different project
from the superman movie that i just mentioned
then obviously you have tyler hoechlin's superman
in the arrowverse so that's five live-action
different iterations of the superman mythos
all on top of henry cavill superman so we
should say that there's six versions if you
include henry cavill superman if the rumors are
to be believed then he's reportedly coming back
in a series of cameos instead of a straight-up
man of steel 2 movie in the next couple of years
the movies that he's been rumored for are black
adam and shazam 2. beyond that is anyone's guess
in the clip that i put at the beginning of this
the story that henry cavill says that he wants to
tell in a new superman movie like a man of steel
2 movie is basically finishing the full arc of his
character that they started in the justice league
snyder cut now originally zack snyder was going to
cover that full arc in the justice league trilogy
superman's fall to darkness the anti-life equation
that we got a teaser for then his redemption with
him eventually becoming the true most idealized
version of the character by the end of justice
league 3. i've already done extensive videos on
the full plot of what justice league 2 and justice
league 3 would have been zack snyder thankfully
revealed all of his storyboards and detailed
story breakdowns so i had a link for that video
at the end of this and down in the description
below because it's crazy but it sounds really
cool based on what zack snyder has told us though
since the snyder cut came out the studio doesn't
really seem interested in finishing his justice
league trilogy he said that he would do it just
as soon as they green lit it but they haven't come
close to doing that so the last we got from henry
cavill's superman arc was the cliffhanger with the
nightmare ending scene with evil superman getting
ready to kill batman and the remnants of the
justice league and the villains working with them
that whole post-credit scene with batman and
martian manhunter was meant to sort of walk
that dark alternate future back just a little and
say hey here's what we're gonna do differently in
this timeline in this time loop flash would have
eventually been able to travel back into the past
to warn batman that we saw a version of earlier
in batman v superman batman would have made the
correct moves in the new time loop they would
have been able to save superman from falling to
dark side of the anti-life equation and used the
big team upgrade with the justice league to defeat
darkseid for good like i said the link for that
full video on justice league 2 and justice league
3 plot will be at the end of this and down in the
description below it gets way twistier and way
crazier with a billion other characters you will
not believe the giant twist they were going to
have at the end of that too like the post-credits
scene for justice league 3. right now i think the
main reason why the studio hasn't officially
greenlit a new henry cavill superman movie even
though they're bringing back a lot of the justice
league actors like wonder woman the flash in the
new flash movie they're bringing aquaman back in
aquaman 2 even ben affleck is coming back during
the flash movie i think is because they just
really did not like the idea of this evil superman
in justice league in the justice league snyder cut
and i think they were really disappointed with the
amount of money that they made on the first man
of steel movie i think they expected to make a lot
more money on that i believe the original plan was
for them to do man of steel then do man of steel 2
but because of the box office performance of the
first span of steel movie they decided to turn
man of steel 2 into batman v superman and make
it a batman movie as well if you remember several
years ago there was like a whole different movie
slate that they had planned out for like the next
10 years of dc movies you could go down that
rabbit hole if you want but i think they're
just afraid to make another henry cavill superman
movie thinking that it won't earn the amount of
money that they wanted to that's why you see
10 batman movies for every one superman movie
right now realistically the best odds of henry
cavill coming back as superman in a big way are
actually probably through the black adam sequels
because the rock is super keen to do black adam
versus superman he will not stop talking about
it he even posts a giant clip of it when he was
teasing the black adam movie i can't wait to show
you more you know i always thought that it might
be cool to hang out with superman that would be
cool right i mean we're kind of similar in terms
of our powers our strengths our speeds because
look at the end of the day you never know black
adam and superman could become friends or they
won't who knows maybe we'll see but before i go
i want you guys to help me out with something it's
something that's pretty important i need you guys
to help me get a message out to uh to some of
the other ones some of the other dc superheroes
let's let flash shazam aquaman wonder woman batman
and superman let's let them know something things
will never be the same because the hierarchy
of power in the dc universe is about to change
so clearly you can see the rock has this
vested interest in doing a lot with the
zack snyder versions of the justice league
characters and because he's so powerful at
warner brothers he has pretty much total
control over the black adam franchise
if he were to tell warner brothers hey i want
henry cavill's superman in black adam to pay
him his money they would do it but hopefully in
the next couple of years by the end of shazam 2
we'll know if superman does show up in some
cameo scenes so let me know in the comments
what do you actually want them to do with
the new henry cavill superman solo movie
the other big thing that's happening this week
is hawkeye episodes are starting on marvel disney
plus so i'll be doing episode videos for that
like all the other marvel disney plus series
make sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you don't miss anything i just did a bunch of
spider-man no way home trailer videos so i'll
put links for those in the description below
too but you can click here to learn about henry
cavill joining the marvel universe playing marvel
characters and you can click here for the full
plot of justice league 2 in justice league 3.
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!